[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN:
Today, we have with us
Pandit Birju Maharaj, who is
the greatest living exponent
of Kathak classical dance.
And he's the recipient of the
Sangeet Natak Akademi Award,
as well as the Padma
Vibhushan award awarded
by the government of India.
And he's from the Kalka-Bindadin
lineage of Kathak dancers.
And he is here for
a very special event
called Paramapara, which
is a concert happening
with the other Padma Vibhushan
winner, Ustad Zakir Hussain,
as well as his family.
He's here with his sons and
his grandchildren to perform.
And so we're in celebration
of his 80th birthday.
So happy birthday, Maharaj-ji.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN: So could
you tell us a little bit more
about what inspired
you to go into Kathak?
PANDIT BIRJU
MAHARAJ: Actually, I
belong to that
family who belonged
about six, seven generations.
So I'm seventh, and
my son is eighth,
and my granddaughter is ninth.
So everybody is getting Kathak.
And they are learning
and performing.
I am so happy.
And here, we perform
together every numbers.
So first time aboard we are
going to perform together.
So I'm happy.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN: Yeah.
That is an incredible,
incredible experience
to perform with your own family
and to share that with them.
I know that I've heard
that you learned Kathak
from your father and your uncle.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: Yes.
My father, Acchan Maharaj.
But the real [INAUDIBLE]
the Jagannath Prasad.
But he was very good,
so good natured.
So [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So it was like this.
Yes.
And my uncle, Shambhu
Maharaj, and Lachhu Maharaj.
Lachhu Maharaj was in Bombay
film dance [INAUDIBLE]..
Many, many films--
"Mughal-e-Azam,"
"Teesri Kasam"-- many, many.
And Shambhu Maharaj
was with me in Delhi.
He was teaching scholarship,
all those classes.
And I also was to get it.
And I was teaching it.
The first, I start to
teach the small one.
Then after some time, the big.
All the older girls and
boys came in my classes.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN:
That's amazing.
And what is one of the
greatest lessons you've taken
from your father about Kathak?
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
He was very happy,
because when I was very
young and my mother always
forced to my father, you
take your son with you.
And he was a little,
sometimes, no.
[CLICKS TONGUE] Yeah.
I was asking [INAUDIBLE],, I was
asking chocolate or something.
It's [INAUDIBLE] that.
But my mother forced, always
you take him with you.
At least he will see
your performance,
and he will learn something.
So always in Calcutta,
Bombay, Delhi,
many, many places when I
was only eight and a half.
And I dance.
You can't believe that
I danced when I was six.
I danced in Rampur stage.
In UP, that is the only stage.
I danced when I was six.
I don't know the
fingers or nothing,
but I was just doing like this.
[LAUGHTER]
So I did that.
And [? Nawabs ?] was very happy
to see me and just call him
to me and sitting on here.
And so much love from him.
And 11 rupees month I would
get in that time, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Salary.
Salary.
PANDIT BIRJU
MAHARAJ: Salary, yes.
And my father was
there about 35 years.
Lucknow and Rampur,
Lucknow, Rampur, like this.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN:
And in your family,
as you've learned about
Kathak over the years,
there's such a difference
in each of the gharanas
and how they teach.
And in the Lucknow gharana,
it's extremely famous
for [NON-ENGLISH] and
how they've brought that.
So how do you bridge the
worlds of [NON-ENGLISH]
and [NON-ENGLISH] and bringing
the technical with the emotion?
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
I belong Lucknow.
And my [? Nawab ?] was
[NON-ENGLISH],, was very--
he was writing [NON-ENGLISH]
and hymns there.
And he likes my
grandfather's [NON-ENGLISH]
and [NON-ENGLISH],,
but everything.
But [INAUDIBLE] but doing the
Krishna and [NON-ENGLISH]..
And while I was thinking,
he's like Krishna.
And all the [INAUDIBLE] go be.
Like something, something.
Very interesting, yes.
So that time, my
great grandfather--
great grandfather, Thakur
Prasad, [INAUDIBLE],,
he came to Lucknow and
popular in Lucknow.
So always in the
court, court dancer.
But every year in Lucknow, there
was one temple of [? barrow, ?]
[? barrowji. ?]
That day, my grandfather was
performing for normal people
who is just a small worker.
I mean, everybody can see you.
But otherwise, nobody
can see other time.
Not a court dancer, anyway.
So those were horse, four
horse, and this, and buggy.
And 4% of us coming to
take my grandfather,
and grandfather was going to--
in the court, like this.
So from the beginning, my father
liked the rhythms in my mind.
From the beginning,
when I was young,
and I was just doing the
[NON-ENGLISH],, tap tap tap,
but not proper way.
But I was playing.
Then my father would
know, in this boy,
there is a rhythm centered.
And Lucknow especially,
there is a very--
[NON-ENGLISH]---- so everything
to see the beauty, the beauty.
So actually, the turn of
the wrist and the finger,
how the pinkies would come, and
the neck, how to move the neck,
not to jerk and nothing, no.
So the beauty of Kathak, how--
as much we can--
do.
And still now, I'm trying that.
Still now.
[LAUGHTER]
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN:
And there's so much.
We've seen so many
of your performances.
I'm sure everyone in this
audience are such big fans.
Could you give us a demo, you
and [? Saswati, ?] to show us
a [NON-ENGLISH] or--
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
Yes, yes sure.
Saswati can tell something,
because she's with me, well,
from 50 years,
more than 50 years.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
And applaud for that.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, it is my pride.
And the pride is
because God is great.
He has given me that
strength of endurance
and that passion that I have
not tired out of learning.
Another 50 years,
also, I think my thirst
will be as it was on the
first day of my learning.
And that unbroken link with the
guru is a blessing from heaven.
So I really am so
happy and so privileged
that I can serve the art
under the guidance of my guru.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN:
That's incredible.
So would you want to show us
a demo of a [NON-ENGLISH]??
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Yes.
I won't tire of saying
volumes about my guru, my art,
more so because I just
came into this profession.
I don't know from
it was destiny.
I belong to a family of
doctors, everyone in my family.
And as a child, I was made
to believe that I would also
follow the same tradition.
I was studying medicine
But as a little girl, I had
started learning dance just
as a hobby.
Not from him, because he did not
teach young ones, little ones.
But I was trained under a
teacher who was a student
of his father in [? atka, ?]
so it was the same tradition.
And then when I received
the national scholarship
from the government
of India, then
that was the first
time when I realized,
because I was
forced to go to see
a professional guru,
professional training,
not as a hobby.
But still, somehow,
my parents never
thought that this would
become an earning for me.
I mean, this wouldn't mean
bread and butter for me,
nor did I look at it like that.
So luckily, I'm happy, in
a way, that, in those days,
we learned art for
the art's sake,
not for any vested interest,
not for becoming something,
not for making any
popularity of oneself.
It's like you need to study.
You need to learn an art
form for your soul and heart
and your mind, your joy.
So there was no push.
I was very slowly moving.
And I really came into a
professional career very late
in life quite unwillingly
against my father's wishes,
who wanted to see
me as a doctor.
I was not happy, though.
So I think when I was
20-plus or maybe 24, 25,
that was when I started doing my
first paid performances, which
didn't make me a professional
but at least more seriously
into the art, into the line.
And then gradually, one or two
of my performances in Delhi
were very much talked about.
And people thought so.
My director and
Maharaj-ji and everyone
explained to my
father and my family.
When I started
really speaking, I
think people would love
to know those times.
I started learning
in the late '50s.
I'm 65 now, 65 years old.
But I started when I
was six years or so.
At that time, there
was still a taboo,
and there were
still reservations
about anyone and
everyone learning
dance, and more so
with women, with girls
coming from decent
families did not usually--
and even if they
learned, it was only
until a certain age and not in
a professional, serious way.
When I finished college and
then, of course, I came back,
I did not complete my
medical studies two years.
And then I came back to Delhi.
Even until that time, when I
was in college, our friends,
especially the boys
around me, said,
what is all this [NON-ENGLISH]
you are doing every day?
What is it every day
you're going to class,
every day you are learning?
What is there to
learn every day?
And I used to fight with them.
But what I want to
make a point is,
those days were very different.
To get a performance,
in Delhi, also--
I think Maharaj-ji and
maybe [NON-ENGLISH] from
the [? baratmatam ?]
school, and a little later,
[? Sonam-ji ?]
from [INAUDIBLE]----
I mean, in a year,
there would be
maybe one or dance performances
all through the year in Delhi.
So as youngsters, no one
had any scope at all.
The scenario has changed
so much, so much, and so
fast in the last 25, 30 years.
Every household
thinks that, yes,
the child should learn some
sort of music or dance.
So quantitatively,
it has grown a lot,
thanks to people like
Maharaj-ji, Shambhu Maharaj-ji,
who were teaching in Delhi and
Maharaj-ji's outlook towards
a modern way of
looking at Kathak,
modern way of seeing rhythm--
seeing rhythm, not only hearing.
And I will let Maharaj-ji--
I will request Maharaj-ji
to define my statement how
one can see rhythm through
nature, through creatures
around us, through
games, through people,
through interaction of friends.
Everywhere, he sees rhythm.
And how beautiful
he has made hundreds
of such rhythmic
patterns so the audiences
understand and relate
to it more easily.
Going back to [NON-ENGLISH],,
unless an audience understands
a little bit and shares a little
bit of what is going on stage,
it'll be [NON-ENGLISH]
for them, also.
And 15 minutes, 20
minutes, and then they
will think it's repetitive.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]-- lines.
The same lines 15, 20
minutes, and that's
it, unless there is
a subjective change
and a variety and a
meaningful interpretation.
And that really is because
of Maharaj-ji, the way
he has seen rhythm.
Maharaj-ji, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
nature, creatures?
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
So the first thing I do,
that [NON-ENGLISH], the beauty.
And still, I'm doing
about that mood.
And before long time,
I was just dancing.
And everybody likes me.
But I could not think so deep
is the Kathak behind the Kathak.
So many thoughts can come.
Then I could find, after
25 years-- when I was 25--
then it is started.
And I could see
that in the nature,
everything is dance and music.
The tree is moving.
The branches and the
leaves are moving.
When the air is coming,
the whole tree is moving.
And the deer.
This is the rhythm, the
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
I just think, they
speak how to jump.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
The line is coming
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
So all the nature, you
know, the air is dancing.
Art is dancing.
[INAUDIBLE] is dancing.
All the [INAUDIBLE] dancing.
So everything is dancing.
And my old god,
Krishna, was a dancer.
Shiva was dancer.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So everybody, [NON-ENGLISH],,
musician, dancers.
[LAUGHTER]
So one [NON-ENGLISH] I tell--
this is the bird is
coming and giving
the food to the small one.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Always is
the counting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] You
could know only the numbers.
But I could see a bird, how
the bird is coming, flying
and coming, and there's the
small one, giving the food.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Baby birds.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: Uh-huh.
So [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BOTH: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: I
could see the number--
[APPLAUSE]
I used the [NON-ENGLISH]
like the wing, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
You know.
This the wing from the
neck, the movement of.
So [NON-ENGLISH].
So I could see many, many
things [NON-ENGLISH]..
But I did all the phone numbers
in my [INAUDIBLE],, you know?
Doctor's phone number.
Always.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But it is of two friends.
One is very lazy
one is very active.
That's two moods.
In my language,
the dance language.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Number one,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN: Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Two moods
of lazy and active, just through
rhythmic bols.
Umpteen number of things
he has made for children,
for addition, subtraction, to
give them that interest in,
because they learn in school.
Then if they do the same through
dance, they connect it better
and enjoy it better.
So every aspect, rhythm of the
universe, everything, my ideas.
We're two friends
coming together
looking for each other.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Two
friends get lost and then find
each other and move together.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
BOTH: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[APPLAUSE]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: So it's
just the distance, search,
come close, and then move
towards the same goal.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: So
many things like this.
And all the language, I
think, there is the rhythm.
If you are taking
correct time words,
then the meaning will be so.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI
SEN: Yeah, it's a--
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN:
Cilantro, yeah.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Spice.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN: Yeah.
[NON-ENGLISH]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: But
[NON-ENGLISH],, if you say,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]--
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Then
no one cannot understand,
because you break a word--
if you don't speak in the
right speed or the chant of it,
then it doesn't make sense.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: If you
say together [NON-ENGLISH],, OK.
But if you [NON-ENGLISH].
The meaning is changed.
So like this, I think all
the language has the rhythm
to say the words.
And many, many things.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: Hm?
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: Yes.
Child, young, and old.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Old.
PANDIT BIRJU
MAHARAJ: The rhythm.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
Just three counts.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Especially for the art, we have
the very particular time cycle.
And you have to all the things,
like the canvas, if there is.
You can't go out.
You have to-- in the canvas.
If you are a painter, then
you have to be there, not out.
Like this, the
[NON-ENGLISH] is like this.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Our
rhythm is the canvas.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: My
[NON-ENGLISH] is a canvas.
And you have to make
everything in there.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[APPLAUSE]
By this beat, you can
say, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
In three lines, all the life,
how the young [INAUDIBLE] old.
So I can see
everywhere, you know.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN: That's
absolutely incredible.
And I think it's
one of the things
that you're so renowned
for, the way you've
taken Kathak as a traditional,
classical art form
and made it understandable
to millions, right?
You've brought it to America.
You've brought it
worldwide, globally.
So what brought
you to that, right?
How did you take Kathak,
which is so traditional,
and turn it into translating
it, to seeing rhythm everywhere,
as you described?
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: That
would be my question, also.
How and when and why did
you think of doing this,
taking nature as your media?
And [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: Few years
before, it came to my mind.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: You're
meaning at least 20, 25 years.
[LAUGHTER]
Because we are seeing all this.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: I'm
writing a [NON-ENGLISH]..
Because this is the
blessing of my grandfather.
Still, I'm writing and
always doing that song.
Like this, I feel
that the audience
would understand if you--
[INAUDIBLE] you can go.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
There's a meaning.
PANDIT BIRJU
MAHARAJ: It will give
the meaning of your patterns
of the rhythm, patterns.
Then everybody can understand.
Otherwise, after
five minutes, they
get-- oh, the same
thing is going on.
Then if you are
giving the meaning
and the action expression
is coming with that,
then it's interesting.
Therefore, I started
thinking this.
And it was very popular, and
everybody could understand me.
Not the dry air rhythm--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]---- but
the [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
The music, also--
[IMITATES NOTES]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So the beats have a
nice cloth on that.
The cloth is [SINGING NOTES]
That cloth on the beats
is coming.
So I feel--
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: And
may I add something to it?
When I was traveling with
Maharaj-ji first time when I
came to America, 1974,
through the Asia Society--
very big company--
[NON-ENGLISH]---- I
realized, of course,
Maharaj-ji has been coming
since '60s, early '60s.
At that time, they realized
much earlier that the two reason
that has the words, the
particular subject of Krishna,
Radha, and others,
[NON-ENGLISH],,
were not so popular and were
not so much well understood
by the audiences.
Now, it's a different scenario.
Now, there's Indians everywhere,
and everyone understands.
So at that point, these
abstract rhythmic numbers
in a universal feeling,
like the flight of birds
or the friends coming together,
as he said, or lazy and--
these are universal.
These feelings
are not restricted
to our Indian mythology
or Indian subject.
Those became very interestingly
understood more than,
sometimes, [NON-ENGLISH],, more
than the lyrics and words.
So I think I was quite a
witness to seeing Maharaj-ji
come into more of these changes.
My little niece, when
she was three years old,
Maharaj-ji was explaining to
her once one pattern of rhythm--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]---- because
my niece is his niece, also.
We are related through my sister
and his cousin's marriage.
So he said, OK, learn
from [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Two, three times, and then
she said, so difficult,
[NON-ENGLISH].
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
That was the first
Maharaj-ji realized.
And he said, OK,
I'll make it easy.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
Then I asked her,
you eat [NON-ENGLISH]?
Yes.
[NON-ENGLISH]?
Then [NON-ENGLISH],,
how many beats?
Three.
[NON-ENGLISH].
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
[CLAPPING ON BEAT]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH],, two.
SUSHRI SASWATI
SEN: [NON-ENGLISH]..
Mhm.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH]..
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN: [LAUGHS]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: Yeah.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
You know, one minute,
she could understand.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Within
just one set, she learned it.
Maharaj-ji's joke.
OK.
You learn it like [NON-ENGLISH].
Later, you can put the
rhythm and words to it.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: And it
made me think [INAUDIBLE]..
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: And
then, of course, she's made--
Maharaj-ji has made hundreds
of such things for little ones,
for adults, uninitiated
adults who do not
understand and appreciate.
So those were the sources,
inspirations, and motivations
that Maharaj-ji got to
make such new changes.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: And
a really special thing
that the Kathak is--
daily life, if you're sitting--
so some people, somebody, they
think like, somebody this way,
somebody [INAUDIBLE],,
somebody [INAUDIBLE]..
So different position
of how to sitting.
And which one is
really beautiful,
my camera is taking that.
That is Kathak.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Kathak
is from the storytelling
tradition, Katha.
So it is very natural to--
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
Very natural.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: --human
body language and expression.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
One might [NON-ENGLISH]..
[NON-ENGLISH] is a Kathak term.
I did [NON-ENGLISH].
[NON-ENGLISH] is this.
Cheek.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Cheek.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: And
how to put the hand here.
Because [NON-ENGLISH],,
the new begum, came.
And he wanted just to kiss.
And the begum told, oh, god.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: She was shy.
PANDIT BIRJU
MAHARAJ: She was shy.
[NON-ENGLISH].
[INAUDIBLE] told
to my grandfather,
make this one get--
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
Because I love the pose.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
So immediately, we
are taking from human.
Naturally, we are learning.
In any small
[INAUDIBLE],, then I'm
learning how the Krishna was.
I'm looking, follow-- ah,
the moment of that boy.
So everything, we are
learning from nature.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN:
That's, again, incredible.
And I've also heard that
you're pioneering a lot of how
Kathak is also taught.
So similar to what
you've described
of how you've opened
Kathak up to the world,
you've also opened
it up to how we
learn as the next generation
who are more disconnected
and may not have the opportunity
to learn the same way we all
used to in the past.
How do you see Kathak
moving in the future?
How do you see the learning of
Kathak continuing to change?
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: Yes.
I have got my own institution,
Kalashram, in Delhi.
And there is-- about
600, 700 students.
My daughter is teaching.
Saswati is teaching.
My son is teaching.
And I think I'm so happy that
so many children is coming
to learn Kathak, because they
say, otherwise, they can sit
and listen to the nightclub.
[LAUGHTER]
But they're sending to me.
You know, this
depend your child.
You are going to temple, or
you're going to nightclubs,
you know.
So many people, no.
But somebody is coming to me.
[NON-ENGLISH],, how to bow
to your mother and father,
how you should talk nicely.
So we are teaching that, also.
And painting.
I'm doing painting.
So I love to--
some classes, I will keep
there in my institution.
Painting, also.
Yoga, also.
And singing and
dancing, that is OK.
But proper way, always,
I'm telling to my student--
just go with your--
and you're eating with hand.
You are walking with your leg.
But never you say,
thank you, my leg.
I could reach with you.
You're my friend.
My eye is my friend.
Because sometimes, people
are doing this thing
and doing this.
So thanks always to your
body that god has given you.
And yes, you do.
When I'm doing [INAUDIBLE],,
then I'm doing,
oh, you did very nicely.
[LAUGHTER]
So the dance is--
SUSHRI SASWATI
SEN: These are some
of the things which the students
and the learners have realized.
And what he's saying now,
he tells to the students,
also, that you are
enjoying your body.
The dancer gets a
beautiful personality, gets
a very nice, pleasant
way of approaching
and seeing the people around,
gives to the audience joy.
All these things.
And then your personality
grows when you are a dancer.
Even when the film stars--
when they come to
Maharaj-ji sometimes,
and some of our students
who have gone into films
and serials in India, they say,
because of dance, we were not--
I mean, no one found
us difficult on screen,
because we knew how to turn.
We knew how to bend,
keeping our personality.
So it adds to not only just that
much of [NON-ENGLISH] dancing,
but your total appearance,
your total walk,
how elegantly you can walk.
I am sometimes telling
these Rampur dancers,
they are going and taking
training from so and so,
so and so--
you, my students, if
you walk on Rampur,
you will walk so much nicer.
And there are a few of
my students, adults,
who goes for some
endorsement somewhere,
[? saties ?] and this and
that, and they say, ma'am,
they were saying you
walk so elegantly.
I said, that's
because of your dance.
So dance gives us so many
things beyond just the learning
and the performances.
As a human being, you
enjoy from within.
You enjoy your soul.
It fills your mind, your
soul, your total outlook
towards society, towards
your people around.
It changes a lot.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN: Definitely.
That nicely transitions
into what I had on mind
next, which is you have
also brought Kathak
to the forefront of Bollywood
and to Indian cinema.
And you've worked in a
lot of very famous films,
including "Bajirao
Mastani," "Vishwaroopam."
And so how is that transition,
bringing the beauty of Kathak
into Bollywood?
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: My
uncle, Lachhu Maharaj-ji,
was in, from a long, long time.
And he called me to join there.
My mother told, if
you'll go to Bombay,
you will be changed, because
Bombay is [? style. ?] No.
Bombay [? style. ?]
The Kathak was there.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
Don't go and live there.
Just work for some
time and come back.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: There will
be more house building and cars
and everything.
You'll come.
I'm going, Mother, don't go.
Otherwise, you've
lost your tradition.
But I didn't go there.
So for the first time
with Satyajit Ray,
the great director,
when he offered,
then I was happy that
I would try to do.
I sang that song [NON-ENGLISH]
and [NON-ENGLISH],,
did that [INAUDIBLE],,
[NON-ENGLISH]..
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: In the film.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
And I was so happy.
And he told me, I
don't want to film it.
You know tradition type
[NON-ENGLISH],, not film.
So he told me like this,
and I was so happy.
I'm going to go, OK.
Then I will do like that.
That was very popular,
[NON-ENGLISH]..
That [NON-ENGLISH] written, that
[NON-ENGLISH],, my grandfather.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: I'm
sure you search anywhere,
Google would help find
everyone that "Shatranj Ke
Khiladi" dance, which is--
I mean, Sanjay
Leela Bhansali-ji,
when we met him first, Sanjay
said, you know, Saswati?
I was almost in love with when
I saw "Shatranj Ke Khiladi."
I said, oh, I wish I knew that.
[LAUGHTER]
So many people, even today,
when I see myself in that film,
it's so beautifully done.
Satyajit Ray has done
such an incredible job.
The costume, the
ambience, and everything.
So that gave Maharaj-ji
that joy of working,
yet not compromising,
with his style.
And that, I think, came with
two or three more directors,
like Sanjay-ji.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: You
could see, in [INAUDIBLE] also,
I did Kathak bow.
[NON-ENGLISH].
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
[? Majira, ?] also.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
That [NON-ENGLISH] was
my grandfather.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And between, there are some
poetry that I wrote that.
So like this, you
know, [INAUDIBLE]..
The song goes very nicely.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Very nice.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: And
it was so wonderful,
that Kamal-ji, having so
many dance forms in the south
and he being so
popular with them.
He chose-- of course,
I think the theme
was like he was hiding,
camouflaging his personality.
But he came day after
day, learning Maharaj-ji.
And he said, Maharaj-ji,
please check me.
Please scold me.
Make me correct.
So the desire to learn--
Deepika, similarly.
My god, the first day
when she started working,
she was so scared, so
nervous, so unsure.
But within a day or two--
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
After two, three days.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: --she
was enjoying so much.
It didn't feel like she had
never learned Kathak before.
It was so easy with her.
So Maharaj-ji made it
so easy and beautiful.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
But I didn't do that
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[LAUGHTER]
Not from here, not from here.
I did Kathak and the turning
body and looking, eyes.
And that, I did.
And for future [INAUDIBLE],,
if somebody would ask me--
nice costume, nice movement.
Then I would do.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN: And
how do you preserve?
How do you find it difficult,
like you mentioned,
as there's so much pressure
to kind of modernize
every classical art
form, whether it's music,
whether it's dance and art?
How do you preserve Kathak?
Or how do you do it?
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: I love
Kathak, and I believe that.
And that's so much deeper.
If you think, then
you can go very deep.
And you don't do it like, I
have my own circle, very big.
Why should I go across that?
No.
[LAUGHTER]
I can create so many
things, you know.
So I will not--
other people,
you'll come with me,
then you help me,
then I will go.
No.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: The language
of Kathak and all these art
forms are so complete,
they don't need to borrow.
People who say they
do fusion because they
think there's limitation within
the style, that's not true.
Because they do not
know the style in depth.
They are not competent
enough to search from what--
look, not only in
the classical--
I mean, not only the
solo forms of stage.
Maharaj-ji has done such
wonderful group choreographies
with so many
contemporary themes.
Some of them are so popular.
We even came to the American
Dance Festival quite some time
back, maybe 25 years or so.
AUDIENCE: 1991.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Yeah.
OK.
And there was a choreography.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
The autobiography of
a piece of iron ore,
what it wanted to become.
It was turned into weapons.
Someone took it up
and put it in the kiln
and made weapons out of it.
And the iron says--
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
I can say in Hindi.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: Yes.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH]..
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: The poetry.
PANDIT BIRJU
MAHARAJ: The poetry.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: When
bad man picked me up.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: In the kiln.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Another
person has taken the other
piece, makes other material,
and make a round shape.
It was [NON-ENGLISH]
in the temple.
The sword was
broken and finished
until the last sword is setting.
I could not make like you.
The sound came down.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: He said--
the last word is, I wish
someone made me like you.
I did not want to
become what I became.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: So
this poetry, I wrote that,
and I composed that.
And I made the painting, also.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
Yes, Maharaj-ji
is a wonderful painter.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN:
That's so beautiful.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
Everything that he imagines,
he puts on canvas and then
starts to choreograph, now,
over the last 25, 30 years.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: A small
movement of the [? bow. ?]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[APPLAUSE]
Could be anything.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[APPLAUSE]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: It's
a [NON-ENGLISH] like that
of so many.
It talks about Krishna's--
the first part of it is about
Krishna's playfulness.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Look, Krishna holds
me, holds my hand,
on the way in front of everyone.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
I went to fetch
water in the well.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
I saw the mischievous Krishna.
I was afraid, because
he was smiling--
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: Laughing.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: --very sly.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Pull at my scarf.
Guerrilla guy, [NON-ENGLISH],,
embraced me in public.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And then the friends react to
his mischief, and they said--
they get together and catch him.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Let him not escape.
Let's catch him.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Let's deck him up like a woman.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: Woman.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Let's adorn him.
And then the poet,
Bindadin Maharaj, says--
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
My grandfather.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Even as a woman, he was so
mesmerizing and so beautiful.
And then, of course,
the last piece.
[NON-ENGLISH].
Can I come here?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
BOTH: [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
BOTH: [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
BOTH: [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
BOTH: [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN: We
are so lucky that you just
did that performance.
So as another
question for you, how
do you see the
role of technology
in helping Kathak and
Indian classical art
forms in helping move it forward
so that the next generation
of people can get access?
And how do you see
the role of Google
and how we can help better
bring Kathak to more people?
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: I'm already
sure when this will go on air,
there'll be thousands of likes
of people liking it and seeing
us.
Technology has helped immensely.
Actually, sometimes, we are
also afraid of our youngsters
going too much towards
only technology
and not learning things--
I mean, directly.
Both are important.
Use of technology
for preservation
for wider promotions
and all is important.
But certain things should
be learned in person, person
to person.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ: I remember
when my uncle, [INAUDIBLE],,
when the lighting came, the
spotlights [NON-ENGLISH],,
then the light man asked, you
want amber one or yellow one
or red one or-- what
kind for your dance?
Look, don't give only
white light you give me.
This color I will think, that
color will go on the stage.
From my eyes, from my
action, that color will come.
Don't give only white, huh?
Don't put anything.
And that time was--
this time was, yeah.
Now, everybody needs-- how
you give to my nose, my knee.
So many problems, no?
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] problem.
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN:
So we are becoming
a little too dependent
and too weak in our own
strength of bringing
out things from within.
And just as I said, as
soon as this goes on air,
people will see it, and
I will become known.
People will see it, and
it will become popular.
But I can promise you,
people who are here,
the way they enjoyed
it here, they
will not enjoy it
through whatever means
they would see on a machine.
So that human life,
especially in these art forms,
like playing a sitar or
a tabla and playing it
through these
instruments, the machines,
doesn't give the
same feeling, doesn't
give the same resonance.
It may be very close
and very perfect.
PANDIT BIRJU MAHARAJ:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
The feeling of the song of
your teacher, what is the sound
is coming, how
they're teaching--
that particularly,
then you feel more.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So I don't believe
in technology, but--
SUSHRI SASWATI SEN: I
would be very happy to have
some of my friends who--
I would be very happy to narrate
a small story, an anecdote,
a story, a real--
[? Jeeva ?]
[? Paani-ji, ?] a director,
when he came to America many,
many years ago for a very--
he was a very learned person.
So there was a very special
dinner with all the scholars.
And he went, washed
his hands, and then
started eating with his hands.
Then someone commented,
oh Mr. [? Paani, ?]
you're not used to
the knife and fork,
and you don't enjoy
your food with that.
He said, yes, I'm used to
knife and fork when I need.
But I enjoy eating
with my fingers,
because it gives me more flavor,
just as I enjoy making love
with my wife through my body
and not with instruments
and gloves in my hands.
So my food is very dear to me.
I know I've washed my--
they said, are you
sure your hands--
he said, yes, I've washed
my hands, and so it's clean.
But are you sure your fork
has been cleaned properly?
Then everyone said, oh,
leave aside all forks.
So something natural
is really beautiful--
a tree growing naturally,
the fruit that it bears.
And if you put all the imitation
into it, all those bad things
into making it grow better
or giving [INAUDIBLE],,
is not the same.
SHRIYA RAGHUNATHAN:
That's very, very true.
And even meeting you in person
has been so enlightening.
We've learned so much.
And I wanted to say thank
you for being such a pioneer
in helping women come
back into dance form.
My own grandmother went through
something similar [INAUDIBLE]..
And we've seen a lot of
how you've brought Kathak
to all of us, both in terms
of how you've brought it
into the mainstream
and how you've
restructured how to teach it.
So I wanted to give
him around of applause.
And thank you for taking
the time to come and--
[APPLAUSE]
--speak with us.